welcome everybody uh to the
theoretically speaking uh seminar series
and specifically to today's lecture uh
on Pace Tech physics and algorithms
couple to enhance technology and I've
got to say that theoretically speaking
is actually my favorite seminar series
within Simons I've learned a tremendous
amount from each and every lecture that
I've gone to on very very topics which
have a theoretical grain in them and
computational as well
um and the Simon's Institute is a
leading venue for threat of computer
science collaborative research we
convene people from all over the world
on different topics that are adjacent or
squarely within theoretical computer
science
and today's lecture
um is going to be given by your Nina
Elda our speaker just a few words about
yunina yunina is a professor of uh
applied in mathematics and computer
science at weitzmann Institute
where she leads the center for
biomedical engineering and Signal
processing she's also a visiting
professor at MIT in the broad Institute
as well as an Adjunct professor at Duke
and uh yunina is a member of the Israel
Academy of Science and Humanities she's
an IEEE fellow she has received many
awards in excellence in research and
teaching including the IEEE signal
processing Society technical Achievement
Award the IEEE AES Fred Nathanson
Memorial radar award
um that's interesting
and Michael Bruno Memorial world
devisement price for exact Sciences the
wolf Foundation Quail prize for
excellence in scientific research and
she does incredibly fascinating work in
compressed sensing single processing and
biomedical applications
um I've been to her lab and it's just
kind of wow you know she's working with
real ultrasounds real MRI images and
today she's going to tell us about her
work and thank you Janina for coming all
the way from Israel
okay so good evening everyone and thank
you so much for coming and thank you
very very much Kathy for that very very
kind introduction it's really a great
honor and privilege to be here and I do
want to say it's even more of a
privilege that Shockey invited me
because really I want to thank you for
being such an inspiration for so many of
us both For You Know Your Excellence in
in research and also for being an
excellent leader uh and also the ability
to take you know groundbreaking science
into practice so that's definitely
something that I've been inspired to
from and uh it's really an honor to be
able to give this talk
so what I want to talk about today is
some work that we and of course many
others have been working on with the
goal of coupling physics and algorithms
in order to try and overcome different
bounds that we have today on technology
so what I'll try to kind of convince you
of today is that by looking together at
physics and algorithms we could develop
technology that is faster smaller lower
power and could overcome different
resolution limits and what I'll try to
do is kind of give you know the the
basic ideas behind what we're doing and
then a variety of different applications
in different areas like Communications
radar Medical Imaging and Optical
Imaging
so today of course we live in a digital
world where more and more of the
processing is being done on digital
devices but if we want to digitally
process real physical signals like this
music for example coming out of the
guitar then we have to have a way to you
know take this music convert it into
bits and then once it's on bits we could
process it on our Computing devices so
this this is really kind of the science
uh behind a lot of the digital devices
and the field that I work in is the
field of signal processing which really
gives us mathematical models and the
mathematical algorithms to process these
digital bits so signal processing has
had a huge impact on technology going
back to Radars in the 50s and then
moving to more modern digital technology
if it's autonomous vehicles you know
hearing aids medical images biometric
recognition and many other applications
[Music]
so I really like this song it's also a
good way to wake everyone up including
myself uh that kind of captures this
essence of sampling right so the signals
around us physical signals are of course
analog they're continuous in time but of
course we get many benefits from
operating in the digital domain and we
have to somehow go from analog to
digital without losing information so
this is done by a piece of Hardware
right which is called an analog to
digital converter and what this
converter essentially does is that it
samples the signal at given points in
time and then it converts those
amplitudes into bits okay so any digital
device really has this ADC in front of
it that enables the digital processing
so let's let's see how this is going to
work right so suppose we have a physical
signal like this red signal over here
and we're going to go ahead and Sample
it in time right so we get these blue
points and all we're going to end up
with are the blue points and we have to
kind of try and figure out right what
was the red signal so you know how do
you do that well you know this this
always reminds me of this uh you know
connect the dot that we used to play
when we were kids right where we have
like all these of course here you have
the numbers so you know how to do it but
you have all these dots and you have to
complete it now why does it work why
does connect the dots work for two
reasons right one because they give you
the points close enough so that you can
kind of trace the image the other is
because you have prior information right
because look at this you have an eye you
have an ear you have a tail you know
kind of looks like an elephant right so
even before you connect the dots you
have prior information and these two
things are actually very key in all of
the mathematical theories of sampling so
it's the prior information and making
the points close enough of course the
question is what is close enough so
going back to the problem we had before
right we only have the dots and of
course the true signal we had before the
original true signal will in fact
complete these dots but there's other
signals that will complete the dots as
well right like these two signals over
here now notice that these upper signals
that I plotted actually vary faster than
our original signal so one way to make
sure that we only have one unique
recovery is to limit the speed of change
okay so this was kind of a very
hopefully intuitive explanation of
actually one of the most fundamental
theorems in sampling Theory which is
Nyquist theorem and what NyQuil says is
that if you want to sample a signal in a
way that you could recover the
underlying signal then you have to
sample at twice the highest frequency in
the signal okay so that is exactly the
picture we saw before that you have to
limit the speed of change
okay so this is a theory a a theorem
about sampling we also have various
different theorems about quantization
and this these beautiful results are due
to Shannon who's the father of
information Theory and for example one
of the problems that Shannon studied is
how many bits could we transmit reliably
over a communication Channel and that
leads to the definition of capacity
which is going to be proportional to the
bandwidth and to the SNR another set of
important results by Shannon is what's
known as rate Distortion Theory and that
basically tells us how many bits we need
to represent a given signal up to some
Distortion okay so if we combine these
results by Shannon and iquest we
basically have the underlying theory for
ADC conversion and any analog to digital
converter today kind of is designed by
obeying these theories okay so it looks
like problem is sums right we have these
theorems from you know many years ago
almost 100 years ago so what's the
problem well the problem is that both of
these theorems depend on bandwidth okay
so if we have higher bandwidth then both
of these theorems imply that we need
higher sampling rates and higher bit
rates and in modern applications that
starts being a real limitation okay
because today we want to use signals
with wider and Winder bandwidth because
we want to convey more information or we
want to get better resolution which
again requires higher bandwidth and that
becomes very difficult to do from from
several aspects one is the actual
Hardware so designing Hardware to sample
at those rates uh is is almost
impossible at very high rates it leads
to lots of data that we have to store we
have to process we have to communicate
this of course also leads to latency and
many other issues that are let's say
technology issues we also have other
limitations so for example High sampling
rates translate in the context of
Medical Imaging into long scanning times
and high radiation so long scanning
times in MRI and high radiation in CT so
at the end of the day this ADC that we
kind of take for granted right it's the
starting point of any digital
implementation is actually a bottleneck
in in many different areas
now a totally different set of
limitations come from physics right from
resolution limits so we know that any
measuring device that we have is going
to be resolution limited so we can't see
with infinite resolution whether it's
time space or frequency so for example
if we look at the famous average
diffraction limit in Optical Imaging we
know that if we're using an optical
microscope then we can't see details
that are smaller than half the
wavelength used for illumination so
we'll be able to see let's say bacteria
but it will be very hard to see proteins
and small molecules okay and this is a
limitation of physics it has nothing to
do with how good our technology is
we also have the same resolution limit
when we look at spatial resolution so if
we're looking for example at antenna
arrays like in radar communication or
even in an ultrasound probe in an
Imaging device the spatial resolution is
again limited by the aperture and that's
why you see you know these huge Radars
in order to get good resolution so
clearly this is a limitation on
technology as well and these are
limitations that are coming from physics
right not from the device itself
so we see that both the physics and the
technology Shannon and nyquist's Theorem
at the end limit what we could do with
technology and the question is you know
is there a good way to overcome that so
basically what we're going to kind of
propose is that you know if you can't
beat them then join them write a physics
and and Technology are giving us
different limitations let's see what
happens when we combine that so
basically what we're going to do is
we're going to use the math to suggest
different ways of transmitting
information where the information is not
something that we could hear or see
directly okay so it's going to be kind
of distorted information but it's going
to propagate better and give us better
resolution so the math will suggest how
we could use the physics to give us
information in a different way and then
at the receiver side we're going to use
the math to extract that information
okay so this is kind of the principle
behind what we're going to suggest in
all of the technologies that we're
developing where really the key thing is
we don't have to be able to hear or see
directly right if we get information
that's kind of scrambled maybe it
propagates better maybe it's easier to
protect maybe there's other advantages
we could get from it and then we'll rely
on our algorithms to extract the actual
information that we need I'm saying that
because you have limits of the
mathematics that's where I'm here in
terms of the devices you you're gonna
you're gonna transmit in a different way
right
exactly but it's not in a conventional
way so it's not in a way that let's say
if it's an image if you look at it it's
just going to look like garbage okay but
I don't care that it looks like garbage
because I could use my algorithms later
to extract what I actually want to see
okay so at the end of the day as long as
my device has computing power I don't
need the physics to to be direct right
like I don't need the waveform to
actually convey the information in a way
that's convenient for me to hear or see
okay but that's not the way standard
things are done today
okay so let me try to make that a little
bit more precise by two examples and
then we'll go back and talk about the
fundamentals so let's look for example
that ultrasound which is something we've
been working on a lot so ultrasound is
wave-based just like Optics and
therefore it's limited in the resolution
okay because of diffraction so what you
see over here this is actually a true
ultrasound of a patient with a breast
lesion okay so this is the lesion and
clearly you see there's a lesion here
but you can see within the lesion okay
so you don't know what it is okay so the
question is you know how could we do
better right how could we be able to see
better so the first thing we're going to
try is to use physics so we're going to
use contrast agents and and this is
something that we actually did so
contrast agents what they do is they
give you better contrast meaning they
reflect the signal better and therefore
the hope is that you know if the signal
is reflected better we'll be able to see
better okay so we injected these
contrast agents into the patients and
then you know you go ahead and take your
image and unfortunately you do see
brighter okay so there's better
reflection that actually doesn't help us
because we don't see within the Legion
in fact in some sense it's even worse
okay so we can't see the lesion at all
but it definitely did not give us more
resolution within the lesion but now we
can use the math and basically okay it's
a little bit hard to see because of the
bright lights here but hopefully you can
see something
um what what you could see could you see
anything okay okay good so what you can
see here is that we can actually see
within the lesion and the way we did
that is by taking this image but
actually tracking the Bubbles as they're
propagating through the blood vessels
okay so this is and I'll go back later
on to how we actually did this but this
is an example of how we're coupling
physics and algorithms so if I try to
track the blood vessels in the original
image I wouldn't get anything because
there's nothing to track on the other
hand the physics alone that injected
those bubbles didn't give me anything
because it just gave me a bright image
but I know the bubbles are in there so
if I use the physics together with the
algorithms I'm actually following those
levels and therefore I could actually
Trace these blood vessels and in this
case again if you're a doctor which I'm
not but we learned this from the doctors
and you could tell unfortunately that
this is a malignant tumor okay because
because of the inhomogeneous that you
could see over here so by tracking these
bubbles we're able to trace out the
blood vessels which we couldn't do
before so this is one example of
combining physics and algorithms where
each one of them alone wouldn't give us
a good result
as another example which is very similar
but in a different area we've been
looking at fluorescence microscopy so we
already said Optics is resolution
limited and and a really really clever
way to kind of get better resolution and
in fact it won the Nobel Prize in 2014
so it's definitely a good method is
fluorescence microscopy where the idea
is that if you want to take a super
resolved image you use these
fluorophores and you control the
fluorescence in each exposure so instead
of taking one image you take thousands
of exposures and in each exposure you
only have a small number of fluorophores
that are actually fluorescent so then
what you could do is you basically
pinpoint each individual fluoroform okay
so think about like an exposure where
you only have three green spots right so
you could just stick a gaussian right
every time you see a spot and then some
over all of the images and you'll get
one super resolved image okay so this is
basically the idea behind fluorescence
and cross microscopy that led to the
Nobel Prize and this gives like a
tenfold increase in resolution so really
really good in terms of station
resolution but it does it at the expense
of time right because now we need
thousands of exposures to get a single
image and therefore you can't use this
for line cell Imaging so here again we
use the same idea where instead of doing
the fluorophores kind of one by one or
five by five we actually let them
fluoresce together so that we cover the
images much faster and then we use
clever algorithms to kind of track these
fluorophores and extract the information
okay so we'll talk more about that later
on but again it's similar to the
ultrasound example where we we take the
exposure in a different way right we let
all the fluorophores kind of project at
the same time but then we use clever
algorithms to separate them in
retrospect and that way we could get
both very good spatial resolution and
very good time resolution
okay so hopefully these examples gave
some intuition to what I mean by
coupling uh physics and math and the
nice thing is that this leads to new
mathematical ideas as well right because
once we use the physics to transmit
signals in a different way basically we
have new mathematical limits that we
could explore on the bounds like the
bounds we said before okay so there's a
nice interplay here between the
technology and also the mathematical
limits
okay so what I want to do in the rest of
the talk is kind of go a little bit into
more detail on how we design these type
of Technologies and then look at a
variety of different applications so
ultrasound radar and and several other
communication applications and at the
end I also want to talk about how we can
use these ideas not only to develop
technology which is focused more let's
say on the on the signal acquisition but
also for purely digital problems like
different deep learning and AI methods
that are totally digitally driven right
there we're not talking about
acquisition devices but these same ideas
of using algorithms and coupling kind of
structure into the algorithms are useful
even for totally data-driven uh problems
so any questions
so far
okay so let's move ahead and talk a
little bit about how we actually do this
and all of the pictures you see here are
pictures that uh of systems we've
actually developed in the lab so if we
look at how systems aren't developed
today they're actually developed in a
very modular fashion so typically we'll
have some transmitter let's say an
ultrasound probe or a radar and signal
and you know we transmit the information
on the receive side the first thing we
typically do is we have a sampler right
because we want to move to the digital
domain and this sampler is typically
going to sample by the night not
typically always by the Nyquist theorem
or more and then we have the quantizer
right we have to convert to bits after
we sampled in time and this is typically
done by Shannon's principle by rate
Distortion Theory which essentially
tells you that for every additional bit
you get 6 DB and SNR so depending on the
SNR you want you choose the number of
bits and then after we sampled and we
quantize right so we get all this
information and then we start doing the
processing right so let's say in radar
and ultrasound you're typically going to
beam form the data so you get all of
this data and you focus it to a certain
direction and then you get your image
and or your delayed doppler map so this
is kind of the standard way systems are
designed and the disadvantage in this
design is that each block is optimized
separately okay so it doesn't take into
account at all any of the other blocks
in the system and as we're going to show
this is actually very wasteful so what
we want to do instead is do this design
together okay not break it up into
blocks where in this joint design
there's three things we take into
account so one is any structure in the
inputs or in the system and since we're
also very often changing the transmit
right we're changing what we're
transmitting we can induce structure and
we'll see that that's very useful okay
so one thing to take into account
instruction
the other thing is the output task right
since systems are designed separately
today anyway for each application right
each application has its own individual
chip or Hardware why not take that into
account rather than doing things
generically and for different tasks we
may be able to sample and quantize in
different ways that are more uh
resourceful than what is done today so
that's the other thing we take into
account and finally like I said before
we take into account that the output of
the system does not have to be
meaningful it just has to convey the
information and we can use mathematical
recovery to extract the information okay
so that sounds rather trivial but again
just not the way that systems are
designed today so like all these three
things we take it for each box
exactly in my input or in my output in
the output task okay so it could be that
there's no structure in the input but
there's structure in the output so if
you have different types I would have a
different sampler
exactly exactly the data
exactly exactly and of course at the end
you want to have things that are generic
in the sense that I don't really want to
change it for every application but if I
could do a class of applications then I
could benefit a lot like for example you
know then people will often say yeah but
that's not good you want things that are
generic but if I build a radar system
right then I'm building a radar system I
the chips in a radar system are designed
for a radar system they're not designed
for an MRI system so anyways at the end
you're building things that are specific
for that system then why not take into
account that it's a radar signal rather
than an MRI signal so it's it's done
anyway but not on this level of the
sampling and quantization
yeah but that's exactly the idea
or Nyquist Theory you know great
Distortion Theory not to mention the
long determinism that comes with
learning
to initials if you went to land right
okay so you could say that I lose there
is no free lunch actually that's a
theory
okay so I view it in a slightly
different way but thanks for that
comment so you're saying I lose Nyquist
theorem I say I benefit because I have a
new theorem so I get to develop new
theorems that take into account the
structure and the end-to-end task and
then I have new bounds and those are the
new bounds that I want to achieve so
it's you're right that I can no longer
apply Shannon and Nyquist theorem but
the goal is to develop equivalent
theorems that take these things into
account so for example we developed rate
Distortion theorems that are end to end
that are not just for quantization but
that are end-to-end rate Distortion
theorems or we've developed uh sampling
theorems that take into account the
structure in the system so those kind of
replace the nyquil's theorem but they're
the same thing right they say you know
given an analog signal and given the
structure this is the minimal rate and
here's how you recover
okay so so you could view it as losing
or you could view it as benefiting from
new theories
I hope that addresses what you meant
okay good good so hopefully as I go
through it will it'll be substantiated
so the other thing that I the comment I
made before and I'm just going to make
it again is that here we're focusing on
kind of analog to digital systems but we
could use the same ideas in purely
digital systems and design kind of
computational methods that are taking
structure and tasks into account even
when they're data driven and we'll talk
a little bit about this at the end it's
not the main focus of the stock today
but we have two recent books where we
kind of go into this more detail one in
the context sub communication systems
and one more in the context of Medical
Imaging particularly in covid-19 but it
talks about medical imaging uh more
generally
okay so now let's start looking at some
classes of examples to make this all
hopefully a little bit more concrete so
what do I mean for example by structure
in the input or in the signal so one of
the early examples we looked at more
than a decade ago was this multiband
problem where we have a signal that's
constructed from several bands of
information each band is narrow but they
could be spread over a very wide regime
okay so the f-maps could be very high
so this is a classical example you get
in different communication problems and
different defense problems in cognitive
radio
Etc so the standard approach to these
types of signals is that because you
don't know the carriers you have to
sample an if Max right following from
Nyquist but that is if you if you just
think about this from like an
information Theory point of view that's
very wasteful right because if Max could
accommodate any signal that is full from
0 to F Max but these signals are Never
full they never occupy the entire
frequency content okay so intuitively
there's there's waste here but of course
the question is how do you do that in
practice if you don't know the carrier
frequency now here of course I'm looking
at communication but we get the same
problem in any medical imaging
application where you image with
multiple frequencies so we've used this
for Imaging problems as well so this is
one class of structure that you could
think of another class of structure in
the time domain which is actually
prevalent in many applications is the
stream of pulses model so in this case
what you actually receive are a series
of pulses where you don't know the time
of rival and you don't know the
amplitude so this happens for example in
radar where you send a pulse and every
time it hits a Target right it's going
to be reflected back so if you could
figure out these times then you get the
distance to the Target and if you could
figure out these amplitudes then you
could extract the velocity of the target
okay so this is how radar works but what
a radar system does is that it just
samples at the bandwidth right which
could be very high it doesn't take into
account that I actually am always going
to have a stream of pulses that's just
how radar works and in fact you get the
same example in ultrasound so although
ultrasound you know at the end it looks
like an image but the way it's formed is
exactly like radar within the probe you
send pulses you get pulses back and
basically to plot a line in the Imaging
you're applying these times of arrival
and the amplitude so it's very similar
to radar okay so this is an example
where this is just the way the system is
designed right so it's always going to
have pulses but it's not exploited today
in the system design so in fact
ultrasound is a little bit more
complicated than standard radar and
that's because within the probe you
typically have between 128 and 256
elements so there's a lot of data okay
the data is taken in all of these
elements and then you beam form it okay
so you align it in time to focus to
every point in the image but the issue
here is that it's near our field beam
forming so you get this kind of
complicated nonlinear equation and then
the question is let's say somehow I
could sample at a low rate but then how
do I beam form at a low rate right
because beamforming is basically
aligning signals and summing them up and
if I sample that a low rate then it's
not clear how I could align on a very
small grid so the difficulty in these
problems is not only the sampling but
also the processing and of course our
goal is to do everything at the low rate
not to have to go back to the Nyquist
rate just to do the processing so we'll
see later on that this could be done and
this is what we call compressed beam
forming so not only could we compress
the sampling but we we could compress
the whole processing chain as well
okay so those are kind of two examples
hopefully they give some concrete
applications is of course many more
examples you could think of but what's
nice is that all of the examples the
ones that I showed and others that I
didn't show they fall very nicely into a
joint uniform mathematical structure so
we can show that all the examples obey
this mathematical model that's called a
union of subspaces and it's very simple
model so what this model says is that we
know a Priory that our signalized in a
Subspace in a low dimensional Subspace
but we don't know which low dimensional
Subspace okay so all of these examples
like the ultrasound multivent or
whatever once I know for example the
times of rival or once I know the
frequencies I lie in a low dimensional
Subspace the problem is I don't know the
times of arrival right so I have an
uncountable number of options only one
of them is correct but I have many many
options okay so this is just
mathematically a union of subspaces
model and the nice result that kind of
this is an example of something that
replaces Nyquist for example so a nice
result we can show is that when you to
sample over a union the rate that you
need is the rate associated with the sum
of two subspaces in the union
irrespective of how many I have even if
I have an uncountable number so the
Nyquist rate is actually the rate
associated with the sum of all subspaces
whereas what we can prove is that the
real rate you need is the sum is the
rate Associated only with the sum of two
okay and clearly two is much smaller
than all and this is really where where
the kind of low rate comes in okay but
of course this is just a lower bound it
doesn't yet tell you you can achieve it
but it does give hope that you could
sample at rates that are much lower than
the Nyquist rate
okay so that's an example of a theorem
that replaces Nyquist
it does it does yeah it would be the
same
I'm just showing Subspace because it's
easier but the same thing
okay so that was just the lower bound of
course the question is how do we
actually achieve it so the nice thing is
that we can actually develop Hardware
that we could prove that achieves
right it doesn't it's not an
achievability yet it just says that you
know this is the the the sampling rate
is lower bounded by this but but maybe
the actual rate is over here and that's
just a lower bat so to show that it
really replaces Nyquist I have to
convince you that there's a way of doing
it
um so so this is something we worked on
already um many years ago uh called
sampling which with the idea of being
compression and sampling done together
and what we could tell here I'm throwing
it pictorially but of course you could
prove all this so what we can show is
that this method I'm going to now
describe actually always achieves the
lower bound so what is this method the
idea let me give the intuition before I
go through the details so the intuition
is right we have all of these options of
sun spaces and we don't know what the
correct one is so what we're going to do
is we're going to Alias them okay we're
going to take all of these options and
project them onto one lower dimensional
space the kind of that lower dimensional
projection has apart from all of them
okay it's like we're linearly combining
them and collapsing them onto a low
dimensional space okay the good news is
that once it's in a low dimensional
space I could of course sample it at a
low rate because it's now low Dimension
the bad news or what looks like bad news
is that now it's all linearly combined
so I don't know which was the correct
one okay so that's kind of the linear
combinations or the aliasing that we're
doing in the in the transmission so to
speak but then what we can prove is that
after we do these combinations if we do
them correctly we could in fact from the
low dimensional projection extract what
was the correct one and then go back and
recover the signal okay so that's kind
of the intuition and the way we actually
do it in Hardware is as follows so we
take our signal we multiply it by our
periodic function here we're doing it
with a few but we can also do it in a
single Channel this is just for
robustness but if there's no noise we
could do it in a single Channel
so we multiply with the periodic
function and from basic signal
processing If I multiply in time right
I'm taking convolution and frequency and
a periodic function in time will always
look like a stream of Deltas in
frequency okay so this is cool because
we get aliasing for free so multiplying
in time is convolution and frequency
convolution with a Delta stream is
aliasing right what will happen is if
let's say this is our input then the
convolution with this we'll take the
signal move it all the way to the right
move it all the way to the left and sum
it up okay so we're getting aliasing for
free we get something that looks like
this but then the point is that we don't
need all of this we could take just one
band okay so this is the low pass filter
we take one band and then we can sample
it at a low rate okay so we're sampling
at a lower rate that's cool we have low
rate samples low rate quantization
everything's nice and simple but what
we're sampling is this Alias version
okay so now we have to go back and
figure out what was our correct signal
okay so this is how it's done in
Hardware we have the pre-processing
which is there this we have the
acquisition at a low rate and then to go
back and figure out which was our
correct index we use compressed sensing
Theory okay which is a digital Theory
but it after we've sampled we are in the
digital domain and then we could use
compressed sensing so I'll say more
about how we use compressed sensing in a
second but just to show that this
sampling method that that I just
hopefully gave an intuitive description
of we could actually prove
mathematically that a it achieves the
minimal rate in all unit of subspaces
models and furthermore it has various
different optimality properties even in
the presence of noise so we can show
that it achieves the common rail bound
which means that it gives us the minimal
mean scored error from all sampling
rates when there's noise and it also
minimized the worst the worst case
capacity loss so if we're thinking of
this in communication context this would
be optimal in terms of capacity as well
okay so like I said what we do is we do
these combinations and after we have our
carbonations we still have to figure out
what is the correct signal so the way we
do that is that we take these linear
combinations and then we use compressed
sensing to get basically an indicator to
which are the correct subspaces okay so
those of you that may not be familiar
with compress sensing basically
compressed sensing is a digital theory
that allows us to recover sparse vectors
meaning vectors that could be very long
but have only a small number of non-zero
values from these linear mixtures okay
so in our case we have analog signals
right I can't I can't just you know
multiply them by a matrix but after
we've sampled the way we have we could
set up the problem this way where X is
basically an indicator function to the
correct subspaces and once I know the
correct Subspace I can recover within
the Subspace
okay so hopefully that kind of makes
sense at least intuitively and of course
in our books we go through much more
detail but then just one thing to point
out is that compressed sensing was
originally developed as a linear Theory
over the years we and of course many
others have worked on extending it in
many different ways for example to
non-linear measurements which is very
important in Optics so we've worked a
lot for example on phase retrieval
um for for problems where there's
statistical sparsity and many other
cases okay so even though the vanilla
compressed sensing um is kind of limited
in terms of applications but there have
been many many extensions uh that that
we and many others have worked on in
order to enable application of these
ideas to a broader set of areas
okay so that kind of sums up sorry yeah
just what's the connection of
compressive sensing in return oh so
there's been sorry yeah I kind of
skipped that so there's been the
standard way to recover signals from
compressed measurements is using let's
say L1 recovery or OMP you know this
kind of standard algorithms to do that
in in recent years there's been a lot of
work on using deep learning to recover
from the compressed samples and that
allows you to kind of move Beyond strict
sparsity so you could look at more
elaborate structures rather than just
pure sparsity so the difference
right yes we don't use again in what
we're doing you know Hardware at the end
and this is something that you know
sometimes people ignore like you could
write anything on paper right but at the
end when you're talking about Hardware
the the input is a true waveform okay so
I can't multiply it by a matrix or or
you know do other things to it it's not
it's it's continuous right so we don't
use any of this stuff to sample the
signal the way the way we sample is
always these mixtures that give me
aliasing but after I sampled and I have
digital samples then I can use these
ideas to go ahead and recover
so deep learning basically just extends
you know the possibility from strict
sparsity to more elaborate types of
structures and you could like it or not
right I mean you don't have to use deep
learning you could still use more
systematic methods
sorry I don't have a recollection that
it actually works so again it really
depends on your data right like if your
data does not have structure then it's
not going to work if your data does have
structure then you know you can use deep
learning methods to find that structure
personally I'm not a big believer in
using generic deep learning for many
things I think in most cases you could
use model based AI which I'll talk at
the end but there has been work on it so
I'm mentioning it here
so there there are a bunch of papers you
know by people who originally worked on
compressed sensing on how you could use
deep learning for more elaborate forms
of structure but the point is that I
could connect that once I have my
compressed samples I could use any of
these techniques to recover
so for one more question if you go back
to can you slice direct when you have
that long and by the end Matrix you have
to have some idea of it and F is in
order to make n the right number yeah
okay really good point yeah that's a
very good point so that really comes
from a union model okay here I skipped
through the math so I kind of all that
brushed under the rug but it's it's like
saying in Nyquist theorem right so in
Nyquist theorem I have to know the
bandwidth to know at what rate to sample
so it's the same thing in the union
model right I mean that's part of my
model my model tells me what are the
dimensions of the individual subspaces
okay so that's something that I'm
assuming is part of my model of course
you could always look at practical
problems when I don't know that exactly
which is the same as saying in the
Nyquist case you know what do I do if I
don't exactly know the bandwidth
okay but but assuming if you're just
looking at the mathematical theorem for
a minute then that's part of the model
how much leadership and be compared to n
yeah okay that's a really good point
right right so that kind of comes that
does come from compressed sensing Theory
and it's nice that it applies also to
the analog domain so that's this K log n
okay so if yeah okay but but roughly I
mean if there's no noise then 2K is
enough okay if x is case bars then 2K
measurements is enough okay if you don't
care about noise and you don't care
about computational complexity the log n
comes from the fact that a you care
about noise and B you want to do this in
a computationally efficient way so you
pay a price a login price
but it's it's usually quite a big
savings with respect to n
okay does that address okay good so the
key here is what you know is going to be
sufficient for solving a problem yeah so
for example let's go back let's say to
the multiband problem so the K would be
the number of users on the channel
okay so the the Nyquist rate right is
the bandwidth which could be very very
large but let's say I only have three
users on the channel so K would be three
okay which could be much much smaller
than the band
okay so there is the issue here right
which I'm kind of ignoring for now as
you know how do I know the number of
users or an upper bound on the number of
users but again that goes back to like
in Nyquist how do I know the bandwidth
so from a mathematical perspective
you're assuming this is part of your
model in practice the nice thing is
again like in many other cases I don't
really have to know it right I just have
to sample at a rate that would
accommodate enough users and then you
know I could do I could do this in a
like what we do in practice very often
is we do this in an Adaptive fashion
okay so I start with like a little bit
maybe higher rate and then I could
recover and if I see that I only have a
small number of users I can reduce the
rate or you could do the reverse you
could start from a low rate and then if
you get garbage you have to increase the
rate
but it could be done adaptively
yes yes yes you can actually
right no but you could detect that you
get garbage because and that's a nice
thing here is that if you didn't sample
at a high enough rate you actually will
not recover as far as Victor you won't
get a wrong sparse Vector you just won't
recover as far as vector okay which is
actually really cool and that's what we
use so what we do in practice is usually
we start low and then increase and the
thing is that you actually do get
garbage if you're at the wrong rate
okay so it's not like you get a wrong
feasible answer you just get garbage and
you can prove that actually
yeah so that's that's that's kind of
what one of the nice mathematical
features here
again but all of this is you know if you
do the mixing correctly so you have to
mix enough to make that happen
okay good
um where was I okay good so so that's
kind of what we wanted to say about
structure
um other important things when we're
talking about sampling are for example
dynamic range so dynamic range in
general is the difference between the
maximum and minimum value that you could
display right so here you see for
example in ultrasound on the projection
they all look bad but if you look at
this in the computer screen so this is
an ultrasound with kind of broad dynamic
range so it looks okay I mean you see
the gray levels and this this is a
machine that doesn't have good dynamic
range so basically you just get a clip
version okay you could see it in images
and we've all experienced this right on
our our phones of course today there's
different Corrections for it but if you
try to take a very high dynamic range
image then you're just going to get
clipping okay now this becomes a real
concern in systems in like modern
systems where you have to accommodate
very different classes of signal so if I
have the same receiver for a
communication user and for a radar user
then you know one of them is going to
saturate the receiver so this is
actually a real concern so here again we
use this notion of aliasing in
mathematical recovery so what we can
show is that instead of getting clipping
what we could do let me just skip ahead
so in a standard ADC you would get
clipping okay if I have a signal like
this and every time it's higher than the
dynamic range it just gets clipped what
we do is that we use a modulo operate
just a mathematical module okay before
we sample and this is like aliasing
right because if you look at the signal
it kind of it looks all Alias right it
just kind of looks like garbage but the
nice thing is that we can show okay so
this is what it's going to look like in
an image we're basically folding
everything to a given dynamic range so
of course this looks bad right but the
nice thing is that we could prove that
this contains all of the information and
we can extract the original signal after
our modular operation okay so so this is
actually real data okay so we get this
folded image and we could go back and
recover the underlying signal and we
could do this of course for continuous
time signals as well so uh this is kind
of to address the dynamic range issue
and again it's just based on you know
mathematical theory that shows that if
you have a ban limited signal you could
recover it from the modulus samples that
that's actually quite counter-intuitive
but anyways I mean you can prove that so
that's kind of cool and you can also
prove that you could do it in a robust
way
is the last one supposed to be better
than the first one though
is the no no no it's supposed to be the
first one rather than clipping so in a
standard ADC you would just get clipping
okay it just Clips it what we do is we
give you garbage okay I just fold it but
then I mean you're not going to actually
see this because I'm going to give you
this but the point is that I fold it and
this is what I sample okay but
mathematically I could prove that all of
the information is here in these samples
so then when I put it through my modular
recovery I end up getting this okay so
this is supposed to be better than this
this was the input okay so this has very
high dynamic range and then a standard
ADC which is clip it
okay and what we're doing is we're first
folding it okay so it's it's this this
looks bad but the point is that this
fits within the dynamic range and this
has all the information in it about the
original signal
see I have a question about the module
operation right is the module operation
here
cheaper than adding more bits to my yes
yes yes yes yes yes yeah so dynamic
range and you know you know much better
than I do but dynamic range is a huge
issue it actually consumes most of the
power of the EDC right because what you
usually do is that you have like an
automatic gain control in order to fit
the dynamic range and that is super
power hungry
just just to give it a linear A to B you
have to trim the resistors after they've
been produced to match the bins
that's actually one of the most
expensive parts of the ADC so it's kind
of cool right because the modular is
very cheap
it's easy to do modulus
it's just not intuitive right because it
looks like you've lost information but
you could again and I'm not saying that
you don't lose information it's just
that if the input is band limited you
have that's a strong enough prior to
recover that lost information so I think
of the modular as just keeping the LSB
is it a hypothetical
right but not exactly not exactly no
because it's the the modular is
operating in a different way right it's
not the same as LSP look just look at
this example right
so it's not exactly the same because
it's folding it first right I mean you
have the jumps up to Lambda
continuity you have the discontinuity
which is it's counterintuitive because
the discontinuity actually increases the
bandwidth okay so you would think that
if I have discontinuities then now it's
going to be harder to sample but the
thing is that those discontinuities
actually give me the exact information
that I need in order to recover the
signal so they're going to be Alias okay
which is why you get junk but again it's
like in compare sensing I have aliasing
but it's useful aliasing so it's the
same thing here
this just reminds me of at the old times
of Distillery projections of the convex
sets we want to find the intersections
yeah
yeah once said images
it is it is very similar these ideas are
similar the point I think is that you
know you could do projection onto
convict sets for a lot of things right
the question is are you guaranteed in
advance that you have a unique recovery
right so you could project but are you
going to get the right result so this
example did you do iterative algorithms
yeah yeah oh no it's not post form it is
an iterative algorithm but you could
prove you could prove two things a is
that you could prove that there's a
unique solution okay so that's kind of a
theory result B you could prove that the
iterative algorithm will converge to the
solution okay so those are kind of again
I'm not going through the math here but
yeah those are the two mathematical
aspects there's a proving uniqueness to
begin with and then B proving that your
iterative algorithm converges to that
unique solution and we do use a form of
projection onto convex sets we just use
a more elaborate you know it's like
projecting gradient okay so it's it's
kind of like projection onto convex
sense but we're using okay we're
actually doing a trick right I'm also
using the fact that I know the jumps
have to be multiples of two lines okay
and that's actually crucial
right one more constraint exactly so
every discontinuity has to be a multiple
of Lambda which is a discrete constraint
but it's actually for you we could prove
it's actually a very useful constraint
keep unwrapping this it's like phase
unwrapping but the difference is that I
could prove uniqueness to begin with
okay so phase unwrapping is like a very
difficult unsolved problem right because
in general you can't unwrap the phase
here I can I could prove in advance that
I can
again I mean that's that's the
counter-intuitive part right
um okay and then another thing that of
course again many people have been
working on but uh we've been doing this
in a slightly different way is is
looking at what's called a Time encoding
machine so changing the way we sample so
rather than standard Samplers have a
clock and then every given point in time
whether it's Nyquist or sub Nyquist or
whatever there's a clock and it tells
you okay every point in time take an
amplitude what we're what we're doing
here is a little bit different so we're
saying we're going to sample every time
something happens okay I navigate this
this is like a little bit of like level
crossing just we're adding an integrator
first okay so we're saying we're going
to integrate the signal and every time
the integral of the signal passes the
threshold I'm going to tell you the time
at which that happened okay so it's a
different representation of a signal but
the nice thing again is that first of
all we can prove that this is a unique
representation of the signal we could
also prove that you could do this at the
same sub Nyquist rates that we showed
before and the nice and practical point
of view is that this does not require a
clock so it's much cheaper from a power
consumption point of view and we could
actually show that we need fewer bits so
in terms of quantization error this is
more robust to quantization error and
intuitively that's because you know an
amplitude let's say if a band limited
signal could change quite a bit so you
could need a lot of bits but on the
other hand if you look at the timings
there are differences are much smaller
okay the time between events are
actually smaller so you need fewer bits
to represent them
if
someone doesn't have a low frequency at
all you might be able to get away with
the pump with the interview or you can
just look at the level of zero code
right but I actually want the integrator
because if I'm looking at so let me
actually show an example so we've been
looking at this let's say for continuous
monitoring of let's say ECG okay
something where you really want low
power and low number of bits because
you're doing continuous monitoring so
for example here okay this is showing
what's happening so this is the signal
this is the integral and then these are
the events so if I was just going to
look at the events themselves right then
if I don't sample enough then I might
miss the event okay but in a sense
because I'm integrating I'm smearing the
event out and therefore I could get away
with a lower sampling rate so the
integral is helping me reduce rate
actually but the nice thing is that it's
invertible okay that I could prove that
I could still recover so if I didn't
have the integral I'd have to sample
more densely
super high frequency
I would still have to sample more
densely because I had like this is high
this is high frequency when I have a
pulse right but then I need the samples
to exactly capture where it happened and
I don't want that I want to be able to
sample at a low rate so if I integrate
I'm smearing out the event and then I
could use fewer samples but the cool
thing is that I could still go back
okay so that's why it's different than
just regular level crossing it also
turns out that it's more robust because
the integral of course integrates the
noise so it also gives you robustness so
it gives you a variety of other
properties as well but it does also
reduce the rate and reduce the
quantization rate
okay good so um I don't know how much
time do I have because I'm going like
slow because I'm happy for all the
questions but I'm trying to think like
what's my overall time frame
so maybe
thank you
ten minutes after the hour because
you've been taking questions as we go
along okay oh my gosh I'm like not even
the third way through okay so
all right I'll speed up here a little
bit okay so let me let me grab them
what
oh this one's fast this is slow okay uh
no no I'm super happy for all the
questions because they make it much more
interesting I just want to know my time
frame so I don't keep people here when
they're you know dying to leave already
um okay so let me just uh
Pastor now okay okay okay okay good I
think questions as we're going along is
better right because then it kind of
makes it more okay good so one of the
things that we've been doing at Weitzman
in the center that we started is really
trying to take these ideas into practice
so we started the biomedical engineering
center in order to really kind of try to
translate these ideas both into
technology and medical applications so
I'm just gonna go through this quickly
and then go back to some examples So
within the center we basically have four
uh kind of pillars the theoretical
research and this goes back to your
question about bounds Etc so to at least
to me one of the fascinating Parts is
actually developing all of these
theorems right so that's what that's you
know part of what I enjoy and so of
course we do a lot of theoretical
research then we have the lab itself
where we develop the boards and all the
technology we have a clinical arm where
we work very closely with a lot of
different medical institutes to
translate these things into clinical
advantages and we have a form that we
started on campus that we call the best
form so between Science and Technology
to try to see how we can use technology
for more kind of scientific discovery
problems so in the in the
um lab part we work closely with
different companies to try and see you
know where we could get different
advantages by using these Technologies
mainly in radar medical and Optical
Imaging Communications and more recently
at Weitzman and more biological problems
uh this is just the subset of some of
the things we work on but I'll stick to
that and then in the clinical arm we
work closely with hospitals to
understand two things one is where could
our Technologies potentially have an
advantage but the other which is more
interesting is kind of really
understanding some of their unmet needs
and seeing okay you know could we
address them with some of these tools so
this is a subset of some of the things
that we're doing more in the in the
clinical domain and we work with a
variety of different hospitals
sorry I'm sorry sorry I was like
speeding it's a more General audience
um so like covered what did you guys do
yeah so I'll get to that uh later on but
like in covid we use these uh principles
of models what we call model based AI
which I'll get to at the end in order to
get very efficient covert detection it's
actually been implemented in Valentine
Hospital during covid so what we do
there is that we use these model based
AI from a simple x-ray to detect if it's
covered or non-covet and that's actually
a very hard thing to do I mean standard
AI you would need I don't know thousands
of examples which we didn't have so we
had a database of like 200 examples that
were all
um you know not a good database right
they're all taken from different
machines different hospitals one the
patient is lying down the other the
patient is sitting I mean not your
standard AI set that you would like
right so a standard AI algorithm would
not work well on them but by using this
model based AI that I'll explain later
on we were actually able to get over 90
uh detection rate so that's kind of an
example of how we use an improvement
yeah yeah the whole point is not to use
large training sets so I'll get to that
I mean most of these examples I'm
actually going to talk about
if if we get there so
um yeah yeah I'm gonna I'll get to these
examples
um okay so let me let me move a little
bit to to applications and then I'll
skip some of them and and so that we
have time for also the model based AI
but uh one of the examples that we're
kind of really excited about are things
that have to do with ultrasound and the
reason is that ultrasound is a very
convenient Medical Imaging device right
I mean there's no radiation you don't
need like a big machine like you need an
MRI and so it should be more accessible
but today there's various different
limitations with ultrasound we'll speak
a little bit about them so one of the
first things that we showed is that we
could form an ultrasound image with much
less data using the ideas that I shown
until now and why does that help us so
now instead of having a machine
we can actually just develop a probe
where we do the sampling directly in the
probe and today that's not done in the
machine so the probe here is totally
analog that's why it goes through our
keyboard because it's actually an analog
cable and everything is just sampled
within the machine because of the high
rates but now we could do the sampling
directly into the probe and then what
comes out of the probe are bits okay
like it should in the digital world and
those bits could be conveyed over any
Wi-Fi channel for example to an iPhone
that Dr hosen could see the image or
over the cloud to some remote processing
hello everybody
of this subject's heart we can see so
what you see here the data is going
directly from the probe to a local
machine to a remote machine through the
cloud and then to an iPad Atrium and the
right atrium we can see the different
structures of the heart we can see the
mitral valve and the tricuspid valve we
can see the nice motion of the leaflets
we can see that actually there is good
ventricular function and there is no
pericardial effusion the picture itself
is very good very crisp and we can
demonstrate very nicely This subject's
Heart okay now he's scanning directly to
the tablet so the point is that it works
just like a high resolution machine
would work but the other nice thing is
that now we're basically freeing the
data so a standard ultrasound machine
besides the fact that it's huge and
costs three hundred thousand dollars it
gives you an image it doesn't give you
data okay but now we're actually freeing
the data so once I have the data I can
use more sophisticated algorithms on the
data and for example this is true data
so again it's a little bit hard to see
on the screen but we're getting better
contrast and better resolution just by
using better algorithms on the data
itself and the other really cool thing
at least for me is again going back to
the physics so now that I have data
instead of just looking at an image I
could look at physical properties of
what I'm Imaging so if you think about
it right if I'm trying to if I'm
reflecting tissue different tissues will
have different physical properties so
for example now that I have data I could
solve physical equations and map out the
speed of sound of an image so together
with a regular image if the doctors use
the thing I can now give the doctor an
image of speed of sound and here for
example this is real data so you can see
here there's a there's a growth here
okay there's a lesion here but it's
actually hard to see where it is right
if it's here or somewhere else but now
when I look at the map of speed of sound
it's clear that it's here and this
tissue is behaving differently because
there's a tumor there okay so I'm not
saying to use this instead of an image
but you could use it together with an
image now that you have the data the
data and all we're doing really is
solving the wave equations on that data
but today it's not done because you
don't have access to the data you just
have the image so
so what's the data here the data is the
actual so what I'm doing is the the data
ultrasound is I send a pulse I get
Reflections coming back and what a
standard machine does today is it takes
all those Reflections it beam forms it
okay so it basically collapses it all to
a line okay and then it moves on takes
another data set collapses it to another
line and that's that's the image that
you get okay and then doctor looks at an
interpreter exactly but these images are
not easy to interpret ultrasound images
are not easy to interpret right they're
just these gray level images
so I'm saying okay the data itself
besides just thinking of it as like beam
forming right as plotting lines it's
these aren't physical wave equations
okay so so and and we know how to
characterize them they're just
complicated right but they're physical
wave equations that I could solve now
now I'll say a minute about how we solve
them but
because it's wave propagation and I
could write down an equation that says
if I'm looking in a certain area right
and let's say I'm looking at the speed
of sound let's just talk about speed of
sound for example so the speed of sound
at every pixel
depends on the properties of the tissue
in that pixel and I know how to write
that down right there's a wave equation
that describes that so the wave coming
back at me will behave differently if if
it hit you know if it the speed of sound
sorry of the wave coming back at me is
going to be different if it came from a
tissue with a tumor then if it came with
the tissue without a tumor okay so I can
actually write down the wave equations
where the speed of sound is a parameter
and extract that parameter from the data
okay and not just think of it as like
beam forming to create an image
so using ultrasound in different medical
you know if it's the heart or the womb
or whatever it will be different
probes and different you have different
data so the the probe would be the same
but the data is going to be different
exactly but that's not these things are
not exploited today because you just
form an image right but now that I have
the data I could say okay why not solve
the wave equations now why do people not
solve wave equations well because it's
complicated okay but when you don't have
access like if you're doing this all in
a machine then and you have huge amounts
of data and this is very difficult to do
but once I'm doing it out of the machine
right because now the data are just bits
that I'm moving to some server and I
don't have huge amounts of data anymore
because I sub-sampled all of it then it
becomes realistic to solve the way of
equations especially because we're using
modern tools right so I'm not you know I
don't know how people used to try and
solve wave equations but basically by
doing discretization and different
Fourier you know it's very complicated
today I could just do back propagation
so I'm not doing deep learning but I'm
using the Machinery that was developed
for deep learning which is basically
optimization solvers and I'm using them
to solve the wave equation so I'm not
using deep learning in the sense that
I'm not learning anything from training
data but I'm using deep learning tools
to solve the wave equations
sorry sorry just
[Music]
industry wave equations characterization
which
is very poorly
um how do you
expanded this into CT into Mr I mean all
of these Technologies really don't
characterize tissue directly and so they
give you
images which people cannot relate to
syndromes as they see Pitt right right
right
no no so thank you so much for the
enthusiasm so as you can tell this is a
paper from like just now so we just
started working on this and we would
love to collaborate with people who know
more about you know the physics of the
different modalities but I I totally
agree I mean that to us at least that's
the path right the path isn't getting
the data itself and then using Modern
Machinery not not necessarily for
learning but for solving equations of
this one totally I mean that's again
this coupling of physics and algorithms
so I'm happy you find it exciting and we
definitely would love to collaborate you
know in different domains the nice thing
about ultrasound is that I could do it
in the lab in my lab right because I
don't like MRI and CT you know it's much
more complicated this I could do in my
lab I could I could take apart their
machine so it's easy for me to play
around with by myself MRI and city of
course you have to work with people who
have the Machinery but we'd love to do
that so definitely
um
sorry
I'd like to collaborate instead of
stealing but
you had a question also before
okay okay
um so I'll skip I'll skip this maybe uh
we could do ultrasound and radar very
similar so everything we do in
ultrasound we can do with radar but in
the interest of time I guess you trust
me we could do this in radar all of
these movies are on my web page so you
could take a look at them but in the
interest of time maybe I'll skip through
the radar uh We've looked we've been
looking a lot at different radar
applications like autonomous vehicles
where again
gaining resolution and reducing cost is
very important we could scan let's say
360 degrees at a time a regular radar
we're just looking One Direction so
there's a variety of different things we
could do in the automotive domain we
could reduce the number of elements so
instead of using a large antenna array
we could use only a subset of the
elements but still get the same
performance so I'm going to skip through
this there's a whole bunch of movies
that show uh some of the radar
applications but again they're all on my
web page so you could go ahead and take
a look and I will just mention this this
application it's radar but it's radar
for clinical so this is something else
that is kind of a new work and we're
excited about is that we've been looking
at how we could use radar in a clinical
setting for example to measure Vital
Signs okay so basically the idea is that
you know the the heartbeat will modulate
the radar signal and if now we have new
techniques to extract information at
very good resolution and very low SNR
then we can now extract these vital
signs from the radar signal so this is
something we've been working on uh kind
of recently and we now have a study in
Schneider Hospital in Israel it's the
biggest Children's Hospital in Israel
where the motivation is clear right like
when you have kids you don't want to
strap them to all of these cables to
monitor a vital signs so we basically
just put a radar on the ceiling and we
can monitor like all the kids in the
room and get their Vital Signs without
ever having to connect anything to them
so this is something we're kind of
excited about where it's an example of
how we take technology and use it in a
clinical setting so those are the type
of things that uh that we like let me
skip this this is going back to kind of
the cognitive radio but I'll skip that
um one one uh thing before we go into
super resolution and AI so that I end on
time another nice area where there's
nice coupling between physics and
algorithms is this domain of meta
surface tenants which is becoming very
hot recently so a lot of people have
been looking at how you can use meta
surfaces so basically what meta surfaces
are these are antennas where when you
change the current through them you're
basically changing their response so
it's a convenient way of getting kind of
low large scale low power antennas and
it's been used a lot recently in
communication mainly as a passive device
so the goal is that you know if I have a
signal coming from a base station and I
have users that are hidden let's say by
this tree then if I put meta surfaces
here I could you know change the current
it will change their reflection and
they'll reflect the signals back to the
users okay so a lot of people have been
looking at this and using this in
communication context but what we want
to do is just like all the things we've
been doing until now is not use them as
passive devices but actually use them as
active devices and modulate the signals
right so everything I've been talking
about of like you know getting all of
these aliasing and linear combinations
now I could use a meta surface and you
know go crazy with the currents but of
course in in a controlled fashion and
that way modulate all of the signals
coming in and coming out in a very
active fashion no longer passive and
totally change the reflections but in
that way maybe get other advantages than
just you know going around a tree so for
example we've we've been using these
let's say on the receiver side to say
you know if a signal comes in
could I take linear combinations in a
very efficient way and in that way
reduce the number of antenna elements
and reduce the number of bits so this is
one thing that we've been working on
another thing we've been working on is
on the transmit side is saying okay
could I now modulate the signals when I
transmit them and maybe in that sense
let's say focus them in a certain
direction very efficiently so this is
actually really cool in 6G networks
because you want to use very high
frequency and large number of antennas
in order to convey large data rates and
what we could prove again this is kind
of going back to the physics is that
when you use large antennas and large
frequencies you're basically operating
in What's called the near field okay so
so signal processing and array
processing always consider far field
right because there's a linear
approximation and everything becomes
linear and makes the math much easier
but it makes the math easier but you
lose a lot of the benefit so what we've
been doing is saying okay could we
actually again go back to the physics go
back to these wave equations right and
focus the waves now that we have this
control on the multiple antennas in such
a way that we could focus not only in a
Direction so when you do the linear
processing you can only focus in a
certain direction but I can't focus
along the line but now that we use the
the spherical wave front in the in the
near field I can actually Focus to every
point in the line not just on the line
and we could do this The Meta surfaces
are are almost free right they're very
cheap so we could do this practically in
a very convenient way and we could get
various different benefits like for
example because I could focus on a line
I could separate very close users okay
so I could get a very good interference
rejection we can also transfer energy
that way right if I want to transfer
energy to a specific point I can just
focus to that point okay so this is kind
of a cool use of principles of physics
to get different signal processing
benefits by focusing in a very
convenient way so let me just quickly I
mean this we already described so I'll
quickly talk about the super resolution
and then say leave a few minutes for the
AI so we already talked about uh super
resolution and the limits that we have
and how we can overcome them with these
fluorophores so just going back to what
I said at the at the beginning what we
do is again it's this aliasing concept
okay so we allow the fluorophores to
fluoresce together but then we kind of
project them and use these sparse
recovery ideas to recover a high
resolution map even though we take a
small number of images so here again
it's maybe not so easy to see on the
screen but storm is the method behind
the Nobel Prize and sparkum is the work
on this we work together with Professor
multisega from the technion
um so this is the method that we've been
using where we're allowing a lot of
fluorophores to project to fluoresce and
then we take these linear combinations
and basically recover the map and this
is a learned version I'll talk about uh
shortly but we can see that we could get
very high resolution even though we're
using two orders of magnitude less
samples and the nice thing is that
because we could do this now quickly we
can now start looking at live cell
Imaging so we've been working with
Professor villantaran from Weitzman
where he's interested in
tiso receptors and basically in their
Dynamic response and until now they
haven't been able to see that at high
enough resolution but they have various
different hypothesis about what should
happen right what they think happens in
these Dynamic processes and now for the
first time again getting data from his
lab and using our techniques we were
able to actually see these processes at
high resolution in both time and space
and this is actually a video it's a
little bit hard to see on the screen but
this is the video that we got from his
lab and this is the super resolved image
using our techniques and of course by
just looking at the center don't know if
it's good or bad right I mean it's
higher resolution but who says it's it's
correct but lucky for us and I guess
lucky for him uh the this kind of
correspondent to what they anticipated
so you know hopefully that means that
that the image we got actually makes
sense and we've been looking more
generally at how to apply these ideas to
biological Imaging we've been working on
this also with the broad Institute and
whoever's interested we have a recent
review where we focus specifically on uh
biological Imaging
so this brings us again to the
ultrasound example I showed at the
beginning where we inject the contrast
agents and then kind of track them and
this is a clinical study we did with Dr
Hoover Goldstein who heads the breast
unit at Burlington hospital and
basically we scanned 20 patients with
different types of lesions and for all
of these patients we had ground truth
right because these were patients that
we had you know MRI pizzitini biopsies
so we kind of know I mean or they know
the doctors they didn't tell us but they
know uh you know what each patient
actually has and like we said before
just injecting the contrast agents
doesn't help it just makes everything
brighter but here you see these are
these are three images and you see over
here all of these images look the same
right if you were just looking at the
ultrasound image you cannot tell right
what kind of tumor each one of these
patients have and and that's why
ultrasound is not really used so much
right for for breast screening it's not
a very convenient tool but if you look
over here at the same tumors at the same
lesions after our post-processing you
could see that they're very very
different right so here you see that
it's very homogeneous genius and this is
actually a benign tumor here you see
that there's only fluid inside and
therefore this is indicative of a cyst
and here you can see that it's very
non-homogeneous and this is actually
indicative of a malignant tumor and like
I said these are patients for which we
had ground truth so we know that the the
results that we got are actually correct
[Music]
I inject these micro bubbles yeah but
what's important to note that these are
patients that have an infusion anyway
okay so they come for like a day so
these are these are all patients right
so they come to the hospital for a day
of different treatments and so from
their point of view I'm not doing
anything special because they have an
infusion anyway and I just the doctor is
doing the same ultrasound Scan they did
before and I'm just injecting instead of
just fluids in the in the infusion we're
putting in these micro bubbles so from
the patient's point of view there's no
difference
no no because they have an infusion
anyway they don't feel the bubbles no
they don't feel it it just costs us
money by the way but I mean there's a
cost to it but a money cost to it but
not from the patient's point of view
it's the same otherwise we wouldn't give
up
for what sorry no injection okay
no no no so this is it's totally macro
right it's it's it just we we don't like
the patient's connected to an infusion
anyway and we just inject it into the
infusion so they don't they don't feel a
difference
cancer but in terms of each of those
separate images then was there a biopsy
done to prove that it was assist or that
it was malignant or yeah yeah so these
patients I mean that they didn't do for
us these are all patients where they
knew this already they knew what each
patient had because so specifically
these patients were chosen because it's
a subset of patients that had MRI PET CT
and biopsies okay so there was total
ground Truth uh so to speak for each one
of the patients but actually the and but
they didn't tell us that I mean we
didn't know we just got the ultrasound
images we didn't know what each patient
had so until now we were talking more
about you know physics and algorithms
and really talking about true physical
signals okay which is which is primarily
you know what we're interested in but
we've also been interested like
everybody else right and you know could
we use these ideas to improve
um AI so okay I don't have to motivate
AI to this audience right we all know
that you know deep learning has been
applied to many many many different
fields in science and engineering and
many more and of course there's many
things that we could do with AI that you
know we couldn't do before we get better
performance in many different
applications
so we could do crazy things for example
like spawning fake faces I don't know
why you'd want to do that but there's
many people who do
um and then you know there's things like
Dali right you could you could say you
know draw me a picture of a man on I
don't know an escalator on the moon and
it will do that so right you could do
crazy things with uh AI which is which
is cool
um but in the applications we're looking
at right we care about different things
so we don't have huge training sets
right if we think about medical imaging
right I don't have you know hundreds of
thousands of images of the same scenario
I'll never get that right so we don't
have huge training sets uh we often
cannot do you know computationally
exhaustive training especially if we're
thinking of you know cellular networks
when you're doing training on the fly
right you you just can't work with like
100 gpus right I mean you just don't
have the Computer Resources
interpretability is key both in like
Medical Imaging or in you know
autonomous vehicles right things where
there's a price to pay if you make a
mistake right so if I draw the wrong
image in Dali nothing really terrible is
going to happen but if I make a mistake
in medical diagnosis then of course you
know that that that has a big price
robustness and generalization are of
course a huge issue that we don't really
know how to say uh and and complexity
right these these networks could be very
very large
so if we go back to model based signal
processing and everything we've been
talking about before right the nice
thing is we have a model once we have a
model we can kind of we could get
theorems we could do optimization we
could prove a whole bunch of nice stuff
and usually we could get inference from
very small amounts of data moreover we
could say how well we're going to do
right like I often know how well I'm
going to do even before I do anything so
I know that you know the worst case
scenario I'm going to get an error of
this size and all of that we of course
learned when we're doing deep learning
okay but so then why do deep learning
well of course there's many reasons but
in particular for model-based networks I
have for model based processing I have
to have a model and very often we don't
have an exact model the other thing is
that maybe I have a model and I can
solve it but it could be very very slow
right so clearly there's many advantages
of learning and the question is could we
merge the two so could we somehow
combine model based algorithms with deep
learning so many many people of course
are working on this and there's many
approaches to doing this
um let me skip this let me kind of just
outline two of the approaches that we've
been looking at and many others and this
is not just our own work many people are
following kind of this Paradigm so one
paradigm is to basically use networks
but make sure that the networks are
inspired by an optimization algorithm
and this is what's referred to as
unfolding I'll show that I'm going to
show what I mean by these two things the
other is the other way around where we
use an algorithm okay we're not using
networks we're using the algorithm but
any place in the algorithm there's
something we don't know we use a network
just to learn that block in the
algorithm okay so these are very two
simple approaches and again we have a
recent review with Stephen Boyd where we
go into much more detail on these
different approaches so just in a
nutshell the unfolding approach actually
goes back to really beautiful paper from
Gregor and lacun but only recently has
been gaining more traction in the
optimization and single processing
community so the idea is in model-based
algorithms right we have some Metric
function we have some regularizer and
then you use your you know favorite
Optimizer to solve the problem so
typically what it's going to look like
is something like this you have some
pre-processing some post-processing and
then you have iterations of the
algorithm so what you're doing unfolding
is you write down several iterations
let's say 10 iterations of the algorithm
and I'm specifically saying 10 because
we normally don't use more than 10. so
you write down 10 iterations of the
algorithm actually if you solve this as
an algorithm you'll get a lousy result
because after candiderations of an
iterative algorithm usually you haven't
moved a lot okay so you're typically not
going to get a good result but what we
do in the last stage is that these
iterations in an iterative algorithm
they're just fixed now what we do is we
free some of the parameters and learn
them from data okay so basically our
Network at the end looks like an
optimization solver but in each layer of
the solver there's parameters that we
learn from training data and the
training data very often is just given
by simulation okay we use the
optimization solver to actually generate
simulated data so that's how we could
get away with using very small amounts
of real data and most of it is
complemented by simulated data okay so
this is one approach and this is a
review that we wrote specifically on
this approach so those of you interested
could see more details the other
approach is super naive and super simple
but very effective in certain
applications which is we take the
algorithm okay let's say the turbi
algorithm which is a dynamic programming
approach to solve symbol detection so
it's an efficient algorithm right it's
not necessarily A solver of some
optimization problem but it's a good
efficient algorithm
what is the problem the problem is that
it requires Channel knowledge so every
time there's something we don't know
like the channel we just in that block
we use a shallow Network okay just for
that block so we leave the algorithm and
just supplement it with a block every
time there's something we don't know and
what we could show both algorithmically
but we can also prove some of this
mathematically is that both of these
techniques again depending on send it on
on the setting actually allow us to
incorporate models and to do it in a
very efficient way so we can prove that
we need less training data and we could
get better at generalization error so I
I think I'm running out of time so let
me just I'll skip this this is right
this is sorry
what do you mean by improper learning
meaning that you have an underlying
simple moment which you don't know but
like in the neural networks because of
functions you include a simple more
and you run learning doing this is
called an importantly so I'm not I'm not
doing end-to-end learning yeah
but basically you're replacing
some unknown model with larger functions
so yeah not not really I'm not replacing
the so let me let me maybe Show an
example and maybe that will be a little
bit more clear okay and if I don't
answer your question then remind me okay
so
starting with the unfolding and again
I'm not I know I'm running out of time
so I'll just you know quickly just go
through the example so just as an
example right we've used this for image
de blurring basically we just set up an
optimization problem with respect to
Total variation use admm that gives you
you know the structure of the network
and then you learn the parameters uh
from data so the network that you get
doesn't look like any existing Network
right it looks like an ADM solver I'm
just learning the parameters
um
so we could use this for you know
various different image de blurring
problems where there's heavy noise where
there's uh you know just areas that are
that are clipped a very heavy blur so
it's it's very effective and it trains
on uh very small amounts of data and at
least from my perspective the important
thing is that it's very principled I
know exactly what I'm doing right so I'm
setting this up as an optimization
solver this goes back to code what I
said before so we've used this uh for
covid when we had very small training
sets
um and and we can show that we could get
over 90 detection from x-ray just to
show that it's not a trivial problem so
if you look at these images and you had
to guess you know who has covet and who
doesn't so this for example looks pretty
good right I would I would guess that
this doesn't have covet I mean I'm not a
trained radiologist but Radiologists
also would guess that so this looks you
know pretty clean so this looks like it
doesn't have Covenant this actually
looks like it does have covet but the
truth is actually the opposite so it's
not an easy problem even for
Radiologists to detect from x-rays uh
you know where there's coven and where
there's not but the algorithm could
actually do it pretty effectively we
could do the same thing from ultrasound
we can use this for more elaborate
problems like separating this is
separating blood flow from from tissue
background and again so going back to
what you said like here what we're doing
is I'm modeling this as an optimization
problem like here particularly I'm
modding I'm modeling this as like low
ring plus varsity and then I'm using an
optimization solver where I'm learning
some of the parameters we maybe I know I
see shoppies yeah we could talk about
this more offline this is the the return
banana maybe this is what you meant by
improper function so I'm not I'm still
using dynamic programming I'm doing the
same thing as viterbi but just the
likelihood itself I'm I'm learning with
the network okay so I don't think it's
the same thing as improper learning but
we could talk about it maybe after I
wrap up
um okay and this is just some of the
theory that we can actually prove that
by using these techniques we get better
generalization and we could use less
training data so wrapping up
um what hopefully I've gone across is
that by coupling physics and algorithms
we could do more from less data and
really like I said first of all this
leads to new mathematical and physical
limits so that's kind of more of the
theoretical side of the story there's a
lot of interesting engineering research
actually developing New Technology based
on these ideas and at least to me one of
the exciting things where I really hope
to collaborate with people who knew who
know more about the actual Fields is you
know could we now use this to get
different scientific and clinical
breakthroughs if we could you know track
signals faster than we could before and
see what we couldn't see before so at
least to me moving forward that's kind
of more of the exciting part and I
skipped through all of the math and so
those of you interested you can find
more details of course in the papers on
our webpage and in our books on the
topic and of course none of this would
have been possible without my amazing
group of students and Engineers so all
of this of course was done together with
their amazing amazing help and my
collaborators that I've had the honor
and pleasure to work with and hope to
extend to other collaborators as well
and thank you very much for all of your
questions and for listening to me for so
long